i've had a lot of time to think and i
made the decision i'm not going to go
back to school after winter break what
ain't got no home
obviously you need to hear this
you're already at a professional level
of drawing for what you want to do
everything in your portfolio needs to be
very clearly coming from who you are
all my heroes didn't go to college do
you know what you get with the ged you
know what kind of job you would get what
gas station i'd love to work in a gas
station
you know i'm looking at a place in
trenton lander whoa
trent
um where would i be staying steven's
room
either
hey
[Music]
uh robert meet our friend wallace so it
says here you worked for a company
called image years ago image comics
i wasn't an artist
nobody get all excited
what would it take for a drawing lesson
honestly you consider yourself a
cartoonist right i pay you how much
[Music]
this is really crazy for me i've just
never met a professional cartoonist
before that's a big deal
i know you need to be harder on yourself
miles if you want to get someplace you
got to you got to be harder on yourself
ring a bell
well you're working for cheryl right
yeah sometimes
you think she's good looking um i'm just
gonna be a minute
oh
my god
okay you are truly
delicious
who is that that's my friend wallace i
forgot to tell you i invited him damn it
look i don't know you or what you're
capable of what's going on in there
robert open the door he's a horrible man
what happens if you come out ruin which
is what's gonna happen
[Music]
it's meant to be fun that's why they
call them the funnies they don't call
them the funniest for no reason
[Music]
just space up to the fact that you
failed
yeah but he failed with soul
okay
you